The Flash Season 3 finale delivered some twists
and turns, an uncertain fate for our hero,
and a sneaky easter egg that likely reveals
the Big Bad for Season 4.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here,
and there's just so much to discuss after
that Season 3 finale, so in this video, I'm
going to break down some of the best easter
eggs from the finale episode, "Finish Line",
and the rest of Season 3, plus I'll be explaining
the teaser for Season's 4 big villain.
Just before I get stuck in, a quick reminder
that my Arrowverse giveaway is running on
this video.
And for a chance to win any of these cool
Funko Pops, be sure to subscribe and leave
a comment about the season finale, season
3 easter eggs, or your predictions for Season
4.
Now, spoiler warning for you if you're not
caught up yet on Season 3, and if you want
a spoiler-free video check out my 10 awesome
facts you probably didn't know about The Flash
by tapping up here.
So, let's start with that shocking ending
where Barry sacrifices himself for the good
of Central City by entering the Speed Force.
The title of the finale, "Finish Line", was
already hinting that Barry would be reaching
an end of sorts and, visually, the shot of
him walking into the Speed Force, which is
personified as his mother, Nora, feels like
an homage to the final comic book cover of
The Flash volume 1, issue 350.
But this episode is a bittersweet spin on
that comic book story as in that issue the
Flash is finally reunited with the love of
his life, Iris, whereas in the show, of course,
he has to leave Iris after spending the whole
season trying to save her.
Just before he leaves, Iris says Central City
needs the Flash, and Barry responds by saying
they'll have one and embracing Wally.
Now, in the comics Wally West took on the
mantle of The Flash after Barry Allen's death,
so is the TV show hinting at that as a likely
future?
I don't think the series would be the same
without Grant Gustin's Flash, and in the 2024
newspaper headline that we saw in the finale
we still see a picture of Gustin's Flash on
the cover, suggesting we will be getting Grant
Gustin back at some point.
The real question, then, is how long will
it be in Season 4 before what's left of Team
Flash venture into the Speed Force with a
plan to break Barry out or before Barry himself
discovers a way to return.
An excuse for Team Flash to rescue Barry from
the Speed Force next season, or for him to
break out himself, would be that they need
his help to defeat the show's new Big Bad.
And in the scene with Savitar and Barry at
Star Labs, there's a clever easter egg for
who we should expect that baddie to be when
Savitar says to Barry, "This is where we came
up with the cerebral inhibitor to use against
DeVoe", and then he adds, "you haven't gotten
there yet".
DeVoe was also name-dropped earlier this season
by the villain Abra Kadabra in episode 18,
and these two mentions are a big tease for
our future Flash foe.
In the comics, Clifford DeVoe is a lawyer-turned-criminal
and is the first villain who took on the alias
of the "Thinker".
DeVoe makes use of a Thinking Cap device that
gives him mind control and other telekinetic
abilities.
Given that Flash producer Andrew Kreisberg
already confirmed that, after three seasons
of speedster villains, the big bad for season
4 would not be a speedster, so DeVoe is a
likely candidate.
Speaking of villains, there was also a cool
easter egg and tease for another DC Comics
villain who I wonder if we'll see in a future
season of The Flash.
The show's penultimate episode dropped a very
cool Wonder Woman easter egg when Barry and
Captain Cold broke into ARGUS and walked past
a holding cell labelled Cheetah, who's a major
Wonder Woman villain.
There've been several distinct incarnations
of Cheetah over the years in the comics, but
her first appearance was back in 1943 when
she was co-created by William Moulton Marston,
who, of course, also gave us the character
of Wonder Woman.
By the way if you're a Wonder Woman fan, check
out my video with some of the best Wonder
Woman easter eggs in season 2 of Supergirl
and, I'll also be making some videos soon
on the new Wonder Woman movie as well.
The title of the episode where we get the
Cheetah tease is "Infantino Street", which
is an homage to the remarkable comic-book
artist Carmine Infantino, who reinvented the
Flash in 1956 when he co-created the character
of Barry Allen.
Among the many other characters Infantino
created are Wally West; Solovar, who appeared
in the episode Attack on Gorilla City; and
the villainous Abra Kadabra, who I mentioned
earlier.
Ok, let's look at some more of the best Season
3 easter eggs.
The titles of the first two episodes of this
season are Flashpoint and Paradox, which is
a sly wink to the animated film, Justice League:
The Flashpoint Paradox, which was an adaptation
of the 2011 comic book storyline Flashpoint,
which Season 3 of The Flash also draws on.
And the scene where Barry battles The Rival
in the season premiere is a clear call-back
to the show's pilot episode which also featured
tornadoes, Barry racing around them, a Weather
Wizard name-drop, and Joe West shooting Barry's
adversary.
And the apple obviously hasn't fallen fall
far from the tree in the West family, because
the way Iris shoots Savitar to save Barry
in this season's finale echoes the way Joe
repeatedly saves Barry in the same manner.
When criminals Sam Scudder and Rosalind Dillon
are transformed into the meta-humans Mirror
Master and The Top, there's a lovely hat-tip
to the co-creator of their comic-book counterparts,
writer John Broome, as the building where
their transformation takes place belongs to
Broome Industries.
And when The Top robs a bank along with her
meta-human partner-in-crime, the colours of
the outfit she's wearing are a nod to the
green-and-yellow costume worn by the comic-book
character she's based on, Roscoe Dillon.
Plus, Wells says there a Mirror Master on
his earth, who uses a mirror gun and is called
Evan McCulloch, and that's the same as the
second Mirror Master character who exists
in the comics.
In The Flash's alien invasion crossover episode,
when Team Flash bring together Team Arrow,
Legends, and Supergirl to face the Dominators,
they all gather in a STAR Labs hangar that
looks just like the Hall of Justice, which
was the superheroes' headquarters in the 1970s
animated TV series, Super Friends.
And that popular animated show gets another
big shout-out in the Flash and Supergirl musical
crossover episode where Barry and Kara sing
a duet called Super Friends, which was written
by Rachel Bloom, the star and creator of another
superb CW show, Crazy Ex-Girlfriend.
The song also includes lots of Flash-related
puns, just like in the comics, a nod to how
Barry's messed up the timeline, and some light-hearted
mocking of Kara's cousin, Superman.
The prolific and influential comic-book writer
Gardner Fox, who co-created the character
of the Flash in 1940, gets a subtle tribute
on this poster when the Trickster commits
a robbery on Earth-3 at Fox Bank.
Given that Barry Allen visits Earth 3 to speak
to Jay Garrick in this episode, it's especially
fitting that Gardner Fox receives a name-check
here as Fox not only created the first Flash,
aka Jay Garrick, but also his 1961 story,
'Flash of Two Worlds' brought together Jay
Garrick and Barry Allen, who inhabited parallel
worlds, and launched the DC Multiverse.
And did you also notice that Fox Bank is located
on Nelson Street?
Which could be a possible reference to another
of Gardner Fox's creations: Kent Nelson, aka
Doctor Fate.
When Cisco suits up to battle the Earth-19
bounty hunter Gypsy, and again later Killer
Frost, the costume he wears is a call-back
on the outfit his comic-book namesake wore
in the New 52 Vibe comics, including its colour
and the quilted textured effect on it.
When Barry's memory is accidentally wiped
in episode 21, he can't even remember his
own name, but when Team Flash tell him he's
called Bartholomew Henry Allen, or Barry for
short, his impulse is for them to call him
Bart instead.
Which is a delightful easter egg to the comics
where Bart Allen is a speedster who, at different
times, takes on the mantle of Kid Flash and
The Flash, and his grandparents just happen
to be Barry Allen and Iris West!
By the way, this isn't the first time Bart
Allen's been name-checked in the Arrowverse.
During the Arrow-Flash crossover in 2014,
Quentin Lance got Barry's name wrong, and
called him Bart Allen!
Now, what do you want to see happen in season
4?
And what were your favourite easter eggs in
Season 3?
Plus, what are your thoughts on the season
finale?
Be sure to leave a comment and subscribe for
a chance to win one of these cool Funko Pops,
which I'm giving away on this Flash video
as well as on my Supergirl easter egg video
and my upcoming Arrow Season 5 easter egg
video.
If you enjoyed this video, do please like
and share it, and check out more of my easter
egg and DC videos by clicking or tapping the
screen here!
Thanks for watching and see ya next time!
Yippee ki-yay, movie lovers!